bands of Hawkins Indiana and the upside
down will finally get to revisit their
favorite characters when stranger things
returns for its much-anticipated third
season on Netflix in july 2019 whether
you're a longtime fan or a relative
newcomer be sure to watch this video
before you check out the newest season
most of the details about stranger
things 3 are being kept under wraps but
we do know a few things to expect from
the new season 4 one thing we'll get to
see the kids hanging out together in
summer for the first time which means no
more battling monsters in between
classes and instead battling monsters
between visits to the community pool and
Hawkins's brand new mall we don't know
yet what the new threat will be exactly
but we also don't know what the mine
player from season 2 is completely out
of the picture yet there are also sure
to be plenty of problems beyond the
creatures from the upside down in the
form of the apparently corrupt mayor
Klein played by Cary Elwes in terms of
where the characters will be when the
new season starts we know from the most
recent trailer that Dustin has just
returned from summer camp several
relationships from season two will carry
over as well including the
father/daughter dynamic between sheriff
hopper and 11 and the romantic ties
between 11 and Mike and Lucas and max
our favorite Hawkins kids are growing up
so fast
the first season of stranger things is
set in November of 1983 while the second
season picks up nearly a year later
kicking things off in Halloween of 1984
Trick or Treat trick or treating that
kind of jump through time allows the
show to play with different pop-culture
references and developments with each
new season but it's also a necessity for
a series that stars rapidly aging young
actors with that in mind season 3 will
time jump yet again by nearly a year
anchoring its story in the summer of
1985 almost two full years after the
beginning of the series the core cast of
adventurous kids telekinetic power
houses and increasingly concerned adults
will be returning for season three but
the next arc of stranger things is also
set to introduce several new pieces of
the show's ensemble cast we might not
know all the surprises but here's who to
watch for an icon of 1980 cinema
join the show this year as Cary Elwes a
Princess Bride Fame steps up to play
mayor Cline an image conscious
politician who's more concerned with
advancing his career than dealing with
horrifying monsters from an alternate
dimension attacking his constituency
Jake Busey will also join the show as a
new major player in the Hawkins
community playing a shady snarky
reporter named Bruce in terms of new
young actors joining the series we have
two big names to add there as well
the first being Maya Hawke the daughter
of Ethan Hawke and uma Thurman Park will
play a new series regular Robin who
works with Steve at Star Court mall and
whose life has changed when she
discovers a dark secret
how many children are you friends with
Francesca rial who stars and Netflix as
haters back off has also joined the
series in a recurring role as Heather a
lifeguard at the local pool given what's
happened in swimming pools in the series
before we have to ask could Heather be
the new Barb perhaps the biggest mystery
we've yet to learn much about since
stranger things 3 is exactly who or what
the Big Bad will be this time around
season 1 introduced us to the horrors of
the lab that created 11 and ultimately
gave us access to the upside down and
its signature monster the demagogue on
season 2 gave us the demo dogs on its
way to revealing the terrifying power
and size of the mind flayer as we've
already discussed the final shot of
season 2 seems to suggest that the mind
player is not entirely done with Hawkins
yet but that doesn't mean it will be
back right away in the season 3 trailer
we get a look at two entirely new
threats that we can definitely say look
like enemies in addition to a rather
unpleasant looking man armed with a
silenced pistol wandering through a Hall
of Mirrors there's that hideous
asymmetrical new monster roaring in a
hallway it certainly looks like another
resident of the upside down is broken
free to terrorize Hawkins but what
exactly is it and how is it different
from what we've seen before the kids
always named their terrifying foes so
what will they call this one all of the
stranger things monsters so far have
taken their names from monsters found in
Dungeons & Dragons and this new guy sure
doesn't look like a gelatinous cube
gelatinous cube eats village I think
it's
stranger things is a show very much
steeped in the atmosphere of what it was
like to be a kid in the 1980s so it was
bound to get around to mall culture
eventually in season three
that time has come at last as the show
revealed in teasers last year 1985 is
the year Hawkins Indiana finally gets a
shopping-center the star Court mall is
the newest local attraction drawing kids
and adults alike to hang out in the food
courts or visit the Waldenbooks and Sam
Goody Steve works there and the trailer
also hints that many Hawkins residents
aren't too happy with Mayor Cline for
bringing them all to the town in the
first place apart from the mall since
summers in full bloom we'll also get a
look at the Hawkins community pool where
the trailer reveals Billy is working
alongside the brand-new Heather as a
lifeguard there is also the Hawkins post
the town newspaper were the new
character Bruce works and we're Nancy
and Jonathan might end up for one reason
or another because stranger things is a
famously secretive series any
information we can get about the new
season at all is valuable and that
includes things that arrive out of
context that's why it was so exciting
for fans earlier this year when Netflix
dropped a brief teaser which revealed
all eight episode titles for the third
season the case of the missing lifeguard
doesn't bode well for Heather and Billy
and the bite certainly seems ominous but
the big one is the season finale the
Battle of Star Court it seems like the
brand new mall might not survive the
season for reasons that have nothing to
do with declining sales stranger things
as a show which proudly and earnestly
wears its influences on its sleeve in
part because of the blend of genres
stories that inspired it and in part
because it's the story of a group of
kids who are at hearts huge nerds these
kids live and breathe the pop culture
which surrounds them which is how we get
the main characters dressed up like
Ghostbusters scenes of the kids digging
through the D&D Monster Manual to put
names to their monstrous enemies and all
the comic book references that Dustin
and Lucas share so do you think 11 was
born with her powers like the x-men or
do you think he acquired them like a
green lantern since the third season is
set in 1985 we can expect certain
influences to play out in real time
including the box-office success of Back
to the Future and The Goonies
adventure that's almost tame by stranger
things standards those are far from the
only films we should look to as an
inspiration for the new season though as
creators Matt and Ross tougher teased
John Carpenter's The Thing as one major
inspiration meanwhile on the other end
of the scale star David Harbor is
mentioned that the new season will also
take a few cues from the Chevy Chase
Private Eye comedy Fletch that's a
pretty big shift in tone but stranger
things has shown in the past that it can
pull off some pretty great comedy along
with the scares between the demagogue
and the mind flayer we've already seen
plenty of disgusting monsters invading
from the upside down in the past two
seasons this time though we should
probably expect it to get a little more
nasty according to co-creator rah
stuffer while it's our most fun season
it also turns out to be our grossest
season I know I know it doesn't look
like much a little gross even right but
consider this with the creator's drawing
inspiration from the thing and it's
infamous monstrosity and citing the
films of David Cronenberg and zombie
auteur George Romero as major influences
we could be in for a whole new level of
body horror and that's before we get
into the scale of things season 2 gave
us a sprawling series of tunnels that
seemed like they were infecting the
entire city and that's not slowing down
as we move into the next season either
the still mysterious new threat was even
played up by noah snap who plays will
buyers when he said the threat is its
brutal it gets bad it's very big like
it's taking over Hawkins the wait
between seasons of stranger things has
been a long one but that doesn't mean
the franchise has just completely shut
down in the time since we last saw the
kids from Hawkins in fact the world of
stranger things has only expanded in the
time since the last episode was released
if you're really missing this world and
its characters you can dig into some
tie-in reading right now I am on a
curiosity wedge and I need my paddles to
travel these books these books are my
paddles in the world of prose we now
have an official stranger things
companion book world's turned upside
down along with two tie-in novels
suspicious minds tells the story of
Elevens mother and the experiments that
were done on her
darkness on the edge of town flashes
back to a story of sheriff hoppers time
as a cop in New York City in the 1970s
in the comics world there are also new
stories to dig into in the fall of 2018
Dark Horse Comics launched a poor issue
stranger things miniseries that tells
the story of what happened to will
buyers during the time he was stuck in
the upside down the company has also
announced stranger things 6 another new
miniseries set to tell the story of a
different girl experimented on at the
Hawkins lab after its debut season
became a pop-culture phenomenon on
Netflix it took 15 months for stranger
things to return for round two for some
fans that seemed like an eternity but
that wait time has already been
overtaken by the long wait before the
arrival of season 3 long's a while want
to be safe I give it a year a year by
the time we get to the new episodes
we'll have been waiting for nearly two
years the delay between season stretched
on into 2018 with no real updates until
Netflix vice-president of original
programming Cindy Holland made it clear
last summer that we'd be waiting a
little while and that Netflix was fine
with that Pollan told a very patient
audience
it's a handcrafted show the duffer
brothers and Shawn Levy worked really
hard and they understand the stakes are
high
they want to deliver something bigger
and better than what they did last year
with everything we've seen so far we're
betting season 3 will be worth the wait
now that the third season of stranger
things is finally almost upon us after a
very long wait it's time once again to
ask the question of how much longer the
show will go on
will we get a fourth season a fifth do
we hope for a sixth will we follow Lucas
Dustin will Mike and eleven as they go
off to college and encounter the pop
culture of the early 90s this is
something that duffer brother is an
executive producer Shawn Levy have
addressed before and the answer seems to
be that the shortest run we'll get at
this point is four seasons of the show
at one point the duffer brothers were
considering wrapping things up with
season four for sure but now they're
considering an expansion as levy said
the truth is we're definitely going for
seasons and there's very much the
possibility of a bit beyond that it
becomes I think very unlikely they might
not get to the 90s or even experience
confusion and disappointment of seeing
ghostbusters 2 but that means we still
have a while left to spend with the
Hawkins gang knowing that there's at
least one more adventure to come check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite obsessions are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]